I had a very busy week what have you
been doing just celebrating oh wait a
minute oh I've got some things really
Michael it's a lovely card with a
picture of Michael on the front this is
one of the talking cards yeah open it
okay let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
is that a good one
the best impression of my voice I've
heard is Tom Hanks really he did it on
the on The Late Show in in in New York
yeah I saw I saw him I was surprised
thanks Andy never done it for me do you
know this there's this shortcut to say
your name as the way they play
people say you say my cocaine yeah
like the drug but loud yeah but I'll
tell you a story about that oh yes a
picture I was making a picture in the
Philippines now I'm in Manila and we
were invited to this very very posh
expensive house to a party and I'm being
introduced to people and saying getting
the drink and all that and the hostess
is standing over there and she's looking
at me rather nastily considering it on
the guest you know and I there was a
moment when I was a bit free and she
went so I went over her and she said are
you a drug dealer
I said no why do you ask
she said why is everybody calling you my
cocaine
you know that story is true that you
couldn't make out a lot of people at the
party going where's Mike okay
graham norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
i know what i do in that situation